elle départ du peloton est donc prévue
jeudi à 14 heures depuis le haut de la
rue nationale à tours pour cette sixième
étape les coureurs vont traverser les
villes de chance et amboise montrichard
saint-aignan où nous ment les fontaines
vous le voyez lucas chopin vous présente
quelques endroits où vous pourrez voir
passer les coureurs en toute sécurité
je me trouve actuellement dans le
centre-ville de noise et juste après
touré chance est là ou pas seront demain
les coureurs pour la 6e étape du tour
ici la commune se prépare quelques
campings cars sont déjà installés
banderoles drapeaux les noiséens en
plusieurs lieux observer la course
privilégiez les auteurs sur les côteaux
à l'entrée de la ville ou bien en plein
centre là où je me trouve
mais attention entre rochecorbon éloize
et le peloton sera encore bien compact
il faudra arriver de bonne heure afin de
trouver une place en centre ville tout
le monde s'active
les habitants vérifie chaque détail
toutes les caméras seront braquées sur
noise et pendant un court instant
j'en suis très heureuse parce que l'oise
et va être remis encore en lumière et
c'est pour nous un privilège que
d'accueillir le tour de france est aussi
le monde découvrira en plus de la france
en plus des jambes d'art et loire ce
qu'est noizet la 6e étape du tour
partira de tours jusqu'à châteauroux
entre les deux villes les coureurs
parcourront des dizaines de villes et
villages
nous partons de noise et direction
amboise
à peine arrivée la ville entière et aux
couleurs du tour des panneaux
interdisent l'accès parking dès
aujourd'hui afin que tout soit fin prêt
pour le jour j
ici à amboise la caravane passera à midi
et les coureurs vers 14h30
c'est tout le centre-ville qui sera
bloquée à cette occasion dès ce soir à
partir de 20 heures jusqu'à demain 16
heures le stationnement sera interdit
sur tout le périmètre de la course
l'un des meilleurs endroits et celui où
je me trouve à l'angle du pont du
général leclerc le virage est serré il
faudra faire attention à ne pas trop
s'approcher des cyclistes pour ne pas
provoquer de chute
en famille entre amis ou encore tout
seul c'est sans doute l'un des meilleurs
endroits pour profiter du tour